[Musik]
sitzt und dann ist schluss und sagt also
ich möchte die ganze sache mich laufen
geht es am orange reaktion sei okay sie
machen politik bradshaw die baustelle
ein ort wo die reine muskelkraft noch
etwas zählt wo frauen nach gepfiffen
wird und der umgang untereinander ruppig
ist in dieser männlich geprägten branche
fühlt sich katrin bachmann wohl die 27
jährige st gallerin ist bauleiterin und
hat auf mehreren großen baustellen das
sagen wie sie sich in dieser
männerdominierten umgebung behauptet und
sich respekt verschafft davon handelt
dieser film
[Musik]
regional bis 8 uhr am morgen
es ist auch so aber nicht ans telefon
also bilder sind auf der baustelle und
der muss sie
als bauleiterin ist kathrin bachmann
täglich auf baustellen unterwegs
sie koordiniert und kontrolliert die
arbeiten aller beteiligten unternehmen
und handwerker hat budget und termine im
überblick
hier in zürich an der klaren straße wird
ein bürogebäude umgebaut und neu
gestaltet
rund 40 leute arbeiten zurzeit auf
diesem platz mit ausnahme einer
architektin alles männer je nach größe
vielleicht ein bis zwei frau entweder
sims malerin xi sondern installateur in
cannes ikk und dann haben die auf allen
baustellen electric könnten komme jeder
plan also und die kann elektroplaner im
brandschutz planerin du dich verbreitung
größten also zügig ein handwerklicher
job auf den baustellen
als seltene spezies auf der baustelle
löst kathrin bachmann gerade zu beginn
eines projektes unterschiedliche
reaktionen aus auf der baustelle für die
andere findet man saalbach limite
bedienten und freut sich mal eine frau
das anders und
[Musik]
wird schwierig schließlich fließe
rausnehmen oder so stück bleibt es bei
danzig aussiedler und gerade 16 man
selber ist nett als zu einer frau als
wenn man gegenüber stehen würde
also man merkt dass die leute ein
bisschen nicht dazu nachdem man als frau
dazu noch jung und mit einem meter 55
nicht gerade eine große erscheinung
fühlte sich nicht immer ernst genommen
es geht immer alle so eine situation wo
man heißt ja sagt ich mache meine zeit
und lust haben
anders als ein mann in derselben
position müsse sie als frau immer wieder
beweisen dass sie kompetent sei er noch
ausschließlich sonntag den punkt ich
glaube die rhodos nöte bringt das nichts
gegen sagen dass du da bist ein tier zu
erlassen und 70 also ich würd gern wenn
sünderin und auf den lebensmitteln und
schwarzer
das war auch nötig halten dich deines
gefiel dann geht es raus du musst
durchhören der rot fordern oder rotkohl
oder die termine d musst du im überblick
die umstürze und du musst präsent
leere tische können schon mal bis über
nachfrage jetzt als ich traue mich
streng ganz selten komme es vor dass sie
als bauleiterin nicht akzeptiert werde
es hat schon so situationen geringen
unternehmen ich habe dann gesagt kann
man das problem die mittelklasse
baureihe gibt es im post oder nicht und
man es eben post sind doch besser die
gelernte hochbauzeichner rinn arbeitet
bei der firma genii 55 prozent der
mitarbeitenden des unternehmens sind
frauen wobei die meisten nicht
regelmäßig auf die baustellen gehen die
frage ob es katrin bachmann als frau auf
einer baustelle schwerer habe als ein
mann löst eine diskussion mit dem
geschäftsinhaber aus eine klare haltung
will nicht dass du große
durchsetzungskraft und das duo aus dem
hintergrund großer beschuss der familie
geschichten sind authentisch sprach ein
schuld der umgang rente und du
eigentlich verschiedenen ebenen hat
später nein das gibt dezitiert zeigt ist
neu aber es hat wie man das als erste
frau und das meeresmuseum mentale anders
bewiesen als eine cd ein bauleiter
wirkung also wie ich überrascht dass du
das spiel nicht gespielt meint auch
sachlich das ist ein witz die einmal
mehr sagen dass es wirklich so frau wie
man bei jedem
ihren durst www nicht irgendwie das
vorstellt da stehe ich vielleicht ein
gegner sache ja weiß sie dass walnüsse
ich meine gewisse etwas mühe in der
grund ist sie hat der hintergrund von
der familie denn ich sehe aber schon
wieder witze kitzeln anders aber das ist
bei mir aus also ist das mindener
traurig wenn ich sage mein vater ist
polier xie yalong canalis in new york
city
ich glaube das geht aber nur in der
beziehung und ich glaube dass man das
ich glaube entscheidend das breite
selber blieb dem schluss die person
respektvoll behandelt du kannst ja und
dann spiels caroline y oder fleisch dass
ich sage ja stimmt
[Musik]
familie h ob die sparmeister und
ärzte immer so einbezug der sommerferien
hat immer alles stimme fasziniert
[Musik]
kathrin bachmann trifft sich zum
abendessen mit der familie vater bruno
bachmann hat ein baumeister geschäft die
beiden jüngeren brüder sind als maurer
und bauführer ebenfalls in der branche
tätig
[Musik]
es wäre naheliegend für katrin bachmann
ins familienunternehmen einzusteigen
doch bietet der vater keine bauleitung
an vorbehalte der eigenen tochter
gegenüber seien keine da mache will ich
schon 20 ist auch ein alter für ihn
mache und drogen glaube ich nicht dass
das bedanken wenn ich sage ich würde ich
gerne die stiege
wenn es einer schaffen sich auf dem bau
zu behaupten dass er seine tochter skoda
zu verhindern dass man sich dass er auch
hier die stimme und das hat viele fragen
wo die tonträger karten oder sie wurden
einige seiten und kann danach xi und das
mobiliar soll praktische gäbe die mauer
stellen und dabei große hebel aussicht
ohne koma und verdient es noch viel viel
schwieriger als frau will dazu jetzt
konnten die rund was weg ist erzählt die
frau bedroht und david pastor und eine
wie diese blöden sprüchen auf durchzug
stellen allen bürgern und sich
durchsetzen
das hat kathrin bachmann mit ihren
beiden brüdern schon früh gelernt
ich bin eigentlich positiv überrascht
dass es so wie braucht hat besetzen
daniel sondergruppe diskriminierung von
frauen offenbar will die wagen sind ja
eigentlich auch liebe dienen und die
ich will jetzt nicht bewiesen ich will
deine zeigen dass ich das auch an einen
großen teil ihrer kindheit verbrachte
sie in afrika der vater hat in tansania
ein kloster und wasserwerke gebaut
die familie war fast neun jahre lang mit
ihm dort einfach mit einer figur gemacht
und darum das sind so niedrig und
erinnere geprägt wo man über deutsche
schule lüfter waren damals die große
duelle mit schaffen kann - und das ist
lustig system schluss schoss gartner hat
muss aber das macht sie nicht von
vornherein andere sieht will meinen
zweifelt man es nicht gegangen ich will
mich grauen oder so ist es kein wunder
dass es funktioniert aber
dieser tweet noch viel bevor ich denke
meine probleme statt eins zu schaffen es
ist sehr schön sie ist platzierung damit
das ist viel viel viel viel wert
die zweite großbaustelle die katrin
bachmann als bauleiterin betreut
am kreuzplatz in zürich entsteht ein
gebäude mit acht geschossen für einen
supermarkt fitnessstudio und büros die
faszination für baustellen hat seit
ihrer kindheit nicht nachgelassen
sich jede dame besonders max wie es
vorwärts geht es ab gemacht hat und
eingelöst hat dass es funktioniert dass
es bereit ist und so sachen sich von dem
aufwand da die decke wetter nicht immer
schon auf der baustelle ist der polier
allen bekannt als pippo der wichtigste
ansprechpartner für die bauleiterin der
portugiese gibt zu auf dem bau freut man
sich wenn eine frau aufkreuzt
mit so vielen frauen baustelle auch mal
locker fragen
beim bau seiner frau es gibt es immer
wieder wo man das rad das mal so bilde
gesät so frauen also ich bin wo sich als
browser ganz schöne bilder sind weil
unnötig meinem antritt sonthofens freude
dran und ich meine was läuft da gehalten
und diverse abnehmer verlegt wird
für mich ist das problem
sie machen ja ostern katrin bachmann ist
tolerant auch was die nackten oberkörper
auf dem bau angehen im sommer gibt es
davon viele zu sehen ob er will oder
nicht
akzeptanz sondern die schwelle wird
einmal ganz andere note dass meine frau
und ich glaube meine frau es auf
baustellen
man darf freut und dann ich wäre dann
das thema ernst nehmen aber es ist
einfach ganz einander die wirklich nur
belanglose im ausland will ich weiß
nicht mal musik und da oben also mit der
single buch frei oder dass man bewusst
heißt dass ich als frau einmal eine frau
müsse sich halt anpassen an diese raue
welt da werde einem nichts geschenkt auf
der baustelle hausfrau den award die
studio nicht irgendwie speziell für dich
dann stellst du dich hof dass sie und
die wahl schon morgen mit muss ich dir
und die arbeit machen und hatte sich
dann aber zwei männer um mich immer
darum ich glaube der baustelle
freundlicher machen vielleicht mit der
vereinbarkeit von familie und beruf
katrin bachmann stellt sich in zukunft
ein leben mit partner und kindern vor
übrigens ihre wohnung hat sie selber
bezeichnet und zusammen mit ihrem vater
gebaut für diesen traum würde sie auch
beruflich zurückstecken
ihren jetzigen job können sie mit einem
teilzeitpensum wohl nicht machen meint
sie
gleichzeitig lassen oder ohne probleme
eigentlich mit sand oder seinen job
könnte die abdeckung wo mir dann mal weg
vor sich bevor dann der schock machte
haben
[Musik]
medien ordens auf dem fußballplatz tanzt
ein dutzend buben nach kathrin bachmanns
pfeife ich glaube das hat zur ego mini
brühe 3 und kollege soll geld aus
irgendwie dort rekrut spenden kollegen
doch auch in ebringen und stellen ihnen
die stimme wie denen ich mag mein
inneres kraft will ich besser mit meinen
umgangs mit frauen aus kohle für mich
einfach dass das geht
[Gelächter]
[Musik]
baustelle clariden straße die
bauleiterin macht eine der letzten
kontrollen bevor das objekt der
bauherrschaft übergeben wird
oder 2 das sehen alle diese sachen ruft
dann wollte ich schon gern das ist der
perfekt ist oder daß es möglich dass
pini besteck gemacht wird das ist ein
ausspruch oder eine architektin sie sich
der spruch erschafft hat und wir möchten
möglichst perfekte objekt an diesem
morgen wird die geduld der bauleiterin
noch einmal auf die probe gestellt
was brauche ich ja steigern sagt
baltisser auch wieder gerecht geworden
oder und in die töne schräg ja wohl aber
dass ich ganz sicher möglich kleinen
spalt vor seinen sounds of 3
es ist frauen erkannt dass wir sagen wir
so kurz vor schluss noch unentdeckter
warum das maß aber es ist offensichtlich
moment
ich glaube ich muss vorstellungen
geboten wenn sie den moment inne wenn es
ist wenn ich am anfang oft draußen
machen und dann spielt sich das leben
nach witterung laufbahn schon purzeln
abgeht das gefühl etwas macht wurde
nicht nur das ich mir die ganze aussagen
die die diskussion dass die migration
meine ziel geführt hat und das zeugnis
meter landschaft mit ihrer
unkomplizierten pragmatischen art einer
guten portion humor und gelassenheit
setzt sich katrin bachmann in dieser
männerwelt durch und solange sie spaß an
der arbeit habe werde sie der branche
weiter treu bleiben
[Musik]